сановник палесі друзі вітаємо вас я
модератор розван то женя програм по
чиркової школи з англійською розумом та
Тетяна Бєляєва
я визнає вчим уроки на платформі та
дірки вигляд би лося шкутильгати скребка
вороненя чайних програм для чітко
ви і школи святий та їх розван теж не за
рукава не їм вікових особливостей дітей
ще навчаються і погодинних класах а так
вже кошторис і вправо анжеліку btn навесні
підходу він овчині
то в те перед нами. ми в 4-му та
методистам та академіками
стояло завдання вилікувати з програм вашке
для прийняття мови
обидва за 100 релізу з місцям а потім ще
повторюється і вона вийде такою програмою
чином ще де ти могли здобувати знання та
києва не зможе ви просто ось його завжди
на мужики
яким видом народжував і їх вимагатиме
прямого life енергію на практичніше мовлення
я ж до вас вдома в обороні взяв і
доля панель 5000 підписувати чиї крики
внесли по not be seen тисяч коментарів
то пропозицій разом з модератор до
місця суми металу та харченка у 4
англійську мови ви ще категорії
заступником директора ми
проаналізували коментарі 1 до
іншого обидва говоріння взяв і навчаючись у
експертному обговоренні програм
частиною представте в академії наук
україни та програми був і розвалений теж
ні а про назву і на рази і доступну і
для всіх на сайті міністерства святі то
наукою україни прийшли шпарит їжа
практичних аспектів змін хотілося abzu
по не таючись на тому почнемо ми поважаємо
мають у пливуть ці зради модель
викладання англійської новий король в 4
на уроці надходив травня but змінена вигляд у
4 центризм біля проходу ми навчені центризм
у вибираємо атаки моделі проведення уроки
у чіп дуже більше проти
а в 4 граф роль старшого помічника то
координатора в 4 англійської вмивати риба
Стати товари шин для дітей оптимістичним
лідером ще води за собою з радістю
побачити ще 7 рокки де ти найкраще
приховує новий матеріал через пісню гру
каску там йдуть сильно буду вати ви вчора
іноземні мови на ігрових засадах
вершині вибач піщинки і лікував кита
рамені
соціальна сфера
це у вас по ну як я повторю в цій
фразою its історію радісної нас три на
wrote a c головні малюк туго ти в піну
на позитивність прийняти, а не знаємо її їй
мови
компетентнісний підхід та ви і в чині
моди на галоші на тому ще в польщу
черву та громада на v-4 ти над їх просто
висловивши і ківано будемо животи у жити і
про використання за своїм
одне лідка ви там у край важливі
практика з дітьми
діалоги у пара до світіння в 4 народять
практикуватися з дітьми діалоги через
інста нізації через зал вчених рожкова
героїв річки де ти може пара їх тіл це
все на уроках
для науковості може бути і викрасти і не
залами нового не фігурки звірів ляльки
для кого оператору фігурки героїв ще
будуть брат і вчать у діалогах можна
зрубати те я просто на уроці з дітьми та
спілкуватися просто модель шини зажадав і
казуси для створу my rose слабкі вже
вирізане обличчя обидва наклейки дуже
рот на спеціальну підготовлену
заготівлю я зміцню згорнути біля вагона ти
ще в діалогах дити може не тільки
знаємо це з 1 за адмін то заплутує а
як справа і ти живеш айпі клава ти все
про потрібні але одного як ти себе по чого
бач чого хочеш і степ цієї чин їх там і
вся
відомо стрибала будинок особи щупі клубиться
моя ніби для літа їх 4 win мій ахметова
бути пат-рай би учинив стирчить і
дітей їх озвучувати
душа важливий елемент для вивчені
молодці а у дивані з прийнятою на
взаємну новий на слух троянду мене того
як то простіше говорити на 7 до того щоб
ти нас упіймала іноземному вояку ванною і
необхідна хрестова на уроці аудіо
відеозаписи про нову не програму за
значен відривалися
аудіоматеріалів c1 двиг волин померлих
інших класах то 2 3 милими у третіх
четвертих класах він же but in і
його лички фрагменти короткі писанки
chant ідеології історії записування на
се але мовляв і ми набридло колекцію
посилання ким і ви на ваш вибір зможе
гру 100 тис. на уроках дуже важливо ви
хрестова ти на дуже з боку опор
для дітей про та за свій не нових слив
обидва граматичні права
в інтернеті та багатстві ресурсі де можна
знайти з крові ілюстрації великого
формату для зливу вимикається в орто ви
кристоф це також книжки великого
формату ці можна демонструвати та
дітям на уроках з але такі короткі
відео, як, наприклад, talking flashcards
ще демонструє дітям нові слова
озвучувати їх ви мовляв все учиняють різанини
природності влади тобто навчається
лаєтеся хто слухає у кого є краще
хіба на візуально пам'ять там на жаль
вчення нового матеріалу з дружиною
животи чан там і
наполегливими візуальними малинками та руками
дуже важливо ви просто ось і принцип
кіпіа
та геть той алфі за головою spans цикли
нависла ви вручається за рахунок
пухлих їх слухання повторення архів
пальчикових nimh всі завдання мають бути
максимально noble ж не дожити, а ви в
чай чати йому місце проживання мер iphone
можна створити у явно ситуацію зістригти
іноземних гостей в аеропорту щось тепле
світло принести внесок у рапорті різьблених
краєм і у я витягну шкіра на dt на
проковтнула з меншої України і потім
заплутує виразку китай можна за промені ти
більше дітей duty ігри виявляють то
є бере інтерв'ю у вас тієї забутої
вчи про третю особу в
із шифру system space всім чотирьом слід
пам'ятають, а то ще на уроці моя буде
дружно позитивна атмосфера
навчання моя but i personally кличе ним
так прив'язаним до реального життя
та у безпечному & sardor ще шкіра дуже
биткина тюрок розуму і на вч і тисячі мусь
людина зможе ви просто те владному
реально можете злити читати історію ти
матова парна сфера там ще вища
мутовані дуже може бути успішним
кожному в 4 у роті пом'ята то шукаємо і
мого розвивати і критичною думками про
своїх учень че ти легко розлучатися зі
інформацію на приклад шок від і слова в
славних у вона вище забувайте
матір'ю